Trump is open to riff for GOP
legislators over his language about the
Kurds yes your Republican is he wrong I
think that on this issue there's a lot
in the way of emotion there's not a lot
way of knowledge I think president Trump
probably made the same decision
President Obama would have made in his
decision because this controversial move
from the troops in northern Syria was
not exactly a betrayal of Kurds so much
as it was a betrayal of the YPG which is
a group of Kurds that we elide with to
fight Isis when President Obama went in
in 2014 he actually tried to alive with
Turkey as well turkey turned that down
so we elide with the YPG the YPG is
associated with the Kurdistan Workers
Party which the United States officially
considers a terrorist organization this
is all very complicated
what now that we've defeated Isis what
the decision was is do we maintain an
alliance with the YPG that is associated
with a group we deem a terrorist
organization or do we ally with our 67
year NATO ally in Turkey I think in the
long run
president Trump probably make the safer
decision but it's going to cause a lot
of consternation and it's going to
continue a sad American tradition that
goes back to the 70s which is abandoning
or Kurdish allies you support the
president's withdrawal I think I think
in the long term this could i rana Clee
end up benefiting the kurds actually
specifically because of David's point it
is true that Charles de Gaulle said
nations don't have permanent friendships
they have interests and in this case
what we're doing far from sending a
message to our allies that we're going
to abandon them we're saying we will
privilege nascent nation-state allies
like our NATO allies over sub state
actors albeit sub state actors that have
helped us in the long run though what
will benefit the Kurds more a temporary
alliance that is constantly fleeting
over the last 50 years with the United
States or a withdrawal perhaps an end to
the Syrian civil war and it looks as
though Bashar Assad is pretty safely
ensconced now in Syria it looks as
though the Kurds trying to create an
alliance with him in the long run what
gives them a better shot for long term
sovereignty and independence in their
region most likely that rather than a
constant state of civil war the initial
reason that Barack Obama allied with the
YPG which is this group of Kurds
despite their association with another
of currents that we consider a terrorist
organization specifically because turkey
which is the second largest military in
NATO would not go in the reason that
they would not back us is because the
official policy of the United States was
not for regime change in Damascus and so
if we're already not pushing for regime
change in Damascus then what is the goal
of our intervention in Syria was to
defeat Isis we did that if we are not
going to ask Bashar Assad then it would
seem to make perfect sense for the Kurds
whose country this is to alai with what
seems to be the safely ensconced leader
Bashar Assad there is no good answer
here you're pitting two US allies
against one another one of those allies
is a sub state actor the other allies a
67-year NATO ally it's it's an
impossible situation and it's it's a
really easy Trump's fault no this was a
situation that doesn't only go back to
the Obama administration I think a lot
of Republicans and conservatives point
fingers at Barack Obama's withdrawal
from Iraq for leading to the rise of
Isis the problem goes back further than
that though because then the left will
point fingers at the Bush administration
were going in and invading Iraq and our
interest in the region has gone back
well many decades before that Henry
Kissinger himself in the nineteen
seventies was using the Kurds as a
bargaining chip against Saddam Hussein
for the Shah of Iran we did it again
after the Gulf War this is a situation
that continues to repeat itself in any
way that we can possibly get the Kurds
into a safer long-term position for
sovereignty is of course that we should
follow yeah I go what's Russia's play in
all of this well they enjoying it Russia
Russia has had an interest in Syria of
course and accurately the role of
Russia's perhaps the most interesting
here because as David says what we're
debating is the role of alliances in
this world the NATO alliance made a
whole lot of sense during the Cold War
after the Cold War after the fall of the
Soviet Union it made a little bit less
sense and so now ironically you have the
same people criticizing Trump for not
choosing to back a sub state actor over
a NATO ally as are the same people who
are criticizing Trump for undermining
NATO and I think there are good
arguments for all of that but the
question is what does America's role in
the world now that we are the superpower
are we going to have a sort of
benevolent Empire where were everywhere
all
the time or are we going to be a nation
state that's what the argument for
nationalism is and the role of Russia
here is key because of rising China I
think if you asked a lot of Americans
who's our greater adversary some group
in Syria Bashar Assad or China probably
they would say China and in the
relations between the United States
China and the Soviet Union for a century
now we have always played one off of the
other so for the Cold War we were often
playing China off of Russia now that the
Cold War is over and you're looking at
an adversary in China there is a in many
ways a strategic interest of the United
States get on better terms with Russia
the Obama administration recognized this
that's why you had Hillary Clinton's
Russian reset and Obama saying that he
would have more flexibility after his
election and I think in some ways that's
why you see President Trump who had
thought trying to push for better
relations with Moscow although he's
being accused of colluding as a result
of that